you know you've been working a lot
working out a lot lately working out ah
you know i've been trying but you know
it's really sad i don't see the result
only because i eat so much not these
days
i'm glad you know that about yourself
well it's because somebody cooks all the
time nobody forces you to eat though
i don't understand what you mean by that
every time you say that i i don't have a
guy
let's have an example yesterday
you air fried hamachikama which is
yellowtail collard which is
quite healthy fishes have omega-3 fatty
acids it's high in protein i didn't
hang on i didn't say it was not healthy
okay and
he was like hey i'm gonna cook all of
these i was like cool and he asked me
would you like some and i said no thank
you i already had my dinner
uh-huh so after he cooks all of them
i'm reminding my own business and
you're like this is so good i don't know
why i would go
to a restaurant and pay for this i made
it so good i'm like that's exactly what
i sound like yeah that's very accurate
go ahead
oh she's so good though he sounded like
a mom
no this is so good he asked me do you
want some and i said no i'm okay
he ended up coming to me giving me at
least
a little piece so i could try his food
exactly a little piece how little was
that piece describe to them
describe to everybody the size of the
piece that i gave you right now point is
if you ever had a dingleberry out your
ass that's how small it was it was just
this dingleberry piece of fish
and you're talking about i'm stuffing
you that that little piece of fish
probably had at most
five calories i don't want to hear that
you were stuffing me
i love your food so yes part of it is my
fault the fact that i can't control
myself
and have your delicious food also you
have
what we call conson which means you have
big hands
that's physical literal definition of it
but what it means is that
you like to cook a lot like you cook
like we have a huge
family like a family of three kids i
know i have
two breasts and i have so i have a big
belly in order for those food not to go
bad as well i have to eat faster or more
you don't have to do anything my dear i
don't like wasting food
you know the thing is that the way we
cook the amount of portion
is very different you cook like you have
a family of five i cook like i have a
family of one
so usually things but we but we cook it
and then we store it in the freezer
to save it for later until you put in
the fridge and you forget because our
fridge is so
yeah but remember what happened though
we didn't go shopping for like almost
two to two
that is why we didn't and now we got no
food in the fridge and all we're eating
is i'm eating eggs eggs
and ramen i'm eating eggs and bread well
i don't understand why you just can't
say no
you don't have to eat the food i love
food i love you exactly so
it's not a me thing it's a you thing i
didn't you need to practice self-control
my dear which i admitted
i know i admit that i said that because
i also love
food but you were saying that the reason
why i didn't yes you did
it's reported part of the reason maybe
you should go rewind this and hear
saying yes i'm not part of any problem
dude i'm the solution
solution to what it's a happy life happy
life that's right you're saying that i
have a happy life
i do exactly exactly you do i do
you have a very happy life very
stressful
time you have a very you have a house
husband that just
cooks and cleans all the time uh cooks i
don't know about the cleaning part
as you know everybody
you cook i can throw you into the middle
of a lake
[Laughter]
did you not cut did you not come down to
a kitchen that was clean today
after i used it
[Music]
did you did you did you die after i used
about 600 days we have lived together
okay after that okay hold on a second
hold on a second i swear to god every
time i have you on this podcast
listen to me i'm changing the name of
this podcast by the way when you're on
hold on a second okay okay after the
last podcast because
your fiance does something we call
active listening okay
i actively listen yeah i realize there
are two
types of listening from you i actively
listened to this
and what happened you see you see any
ramen bowls with soup inside it
no my dear i washed that [ __ ] up and i
threw that [ __ ] in the dishwasher that's
right i am so
glad i noticed it too and i acknowledged
it i was like
exactly did you put the dishes away so
now
i'm literally two paces away from being
perfect so at this point
i don't want to hear nothing from you
all right at this point okay
after one day actually one morning
okay but you know what kudos to you once
one step at a time
one step forward is a step in the right
direction exactly and i'm like
everybody one step forward is a step
in the right direction thessalonians 5
18
4 16 divided by 2.
1.2 one step forward
is a step in the right direction
all right pastor so okay go and have
your own mosaic now when god
came when god when god came down
and he looked at us see we were created
in the image of god we were created in
the image of god
amen right god doesn't expect perfection
out of me god expects me just to be a
reflection of his image and try my best
to do so
if not it's not about
that it's not it's not about what you
want to shut up it's not about
perfection
because one step forward is a step in
the right direction are you laughing at
god right now
i swear i swear to myself
wow that was amazing thank you that was
a great performance i told you i used to
be a pastor i know i still got it in my
gosh
oh you made me cry right there amen
hallelujah amen hallelujah
copy and paste today's morning to every
day you know i i do want to say this
though
just because i've been hearing i've been
hearing a lot of
you know far far be it that she and i
are anywhere near close to being perfect
we're not we're a hot disaster
especially the
the the trials and tribulations that
that we went through just to get to
where we are right now
and she does some stuff that still
pisses me off absolutely but um
every day late night mario's weird huh
you want to talk about that let's talk
about that farting thing you have been
farting
so much recently it's unreal excuse me i
fart at night you fought in the morning
okay that's what it is my dear you fart
at night you fart during the day
you fart during brunch you fart during
prayer you fart
you fart during siesta fiesta everything
dude it means
circulating i would think that the
amount of fart that you had you would
just start flying in the air how much
you fart
i'm because we don't have food too
nowadays i'm eating a bowl of edamame
every night
that's a beet that's a lot of beans
you've only been eating
edamame for the past couple of days yes
and you've been [ __ ]
what are you saying for the past you've
farted so much
it means it's circulating very well down
there and
hey and i like when you fart too you
just you're just stone cold face too
you're hoping that i don't even notice
but the problem is it's not that her
fart smells it's it doesn't smell fart
is
violent it's violently purple
her fart is as violent and loud as a
prison outbreak
that thing it rumbles the earth you know
every time
but it got no smell which on the other
hand
this man when's the last time you
smelled my fart
i don't know exactly what room smells in
the morning
it's not it's not fart smell dude that's
not far smell though that's natural
man's smell morning i'm like
what the hell is this that's not that i
swear i had the candle light on last
night
where is my my glade candle i turned it
on for
hours hoping that it would save the
morning
but no it doesn't so here's the thing if
any ladies out there have not lived with
a man
if you have not had a male sibling if
you have not smelled
your father's room in the morning for
some reason i don't know what it is and
i only know this because when mario
lived separately from me when i walked
into her room
or when we when i spent the night only
one night in her bedroom
the room smelled fantastic for some
reason men
exude this stinky odor out of their body
it's all guys do you smell it
i smell it it just smells like dude like
like the exhale of a dude
how do you smell it it doesn't smell
nice it's just like oh this is weird so
you know opening up the windows helps
out a lot
but i don't know why men smell so much
worse than women because you know me
every night before i go to sleep what do
i do yeah you're a very clean i shower
yeah i shower i brush my teeth i do
everything two three times a day
and then but in the morning it just it
smells like man oil
and you don't smell it throughout the
day too exactly so i don't know what it
is at night
maybe i'm